aquí tengo una figura que es como una
caja y se llama prisma rectangular nos
dan las dimensiones y a partir de eso
queremos medir el volumen la unidad que
vamos a utilizar para medir el volumen
la puse por aquí y es un cúbito unitario
es decir un cúbito en el cual cada uno
de los lados mide una unidad
las unidades que estamos utilizando son
centímetros entonces a esta unidad le
llamamos un centímetro cúbico un
centímetro cúbico y como ya platicamos
en vídeos anteriores lo que queremos
hacer es básicamente ver cuántos cuántos
centímetros cúbicos o cuántos de estos
cubitos caben en el prisma de acá vale
ya platicamos que podemos contarlos pero
aquí como no se ven todos los cubitos
podría resultar un poco difícil entonces
queremos platicar de otras tácticas para
obtener el volumen de un prisma vale
bueno veamos que tenemos dos centímetros
de ancho tres centímetros de profundidad
y cuatro centímetros de alto entonces a
lo mejor de alguna forma podemos
utilizar estos números para determinar
el volumen si tiene sin tener que contar
todos los
que caben aquí vale bueno lo que vamos a
hacer es partir este prisma en rebanadas
a qué me refiero con esto
imagínate que hacemos un corte del
prisma más o menos como por aquí como
por aquí y nada más nos fijamos en esta
rebanada vale lo puse aquí abajo es esta
mismísima rebanada de acá va entonces
aquí tenemos esta rebanada y lo que
queremos hacer es pensar cómo podemos
utilizar esta rebanada para determinar
el volumen bueno pues podemos empezar
contando los cubitos de aquí que serían
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 sin embargo no siempre
es tan fácil contar los cubitos en una
rebanada podría ser así podrían ser así
muchísimos pero entonces lo que podemos
hacer es simplemente determinar el área
de esta superficie que determinan la
rebanada porque entonces como como la
rebanada es de un centímetro de
profundidad
tendríamos que eso justo es la cantidad
de cubitos de la rebanada déjame
explicarte un poco mejor a qué me
refiero osea aquí tenemos dos
centímetros
a dos centímetros de largo y cuatro
centímetros de alto entonces aquí voy a
marcar los cuatro centímetros de alto
cuatro centímetros entonces el área de
esta de esta superficie de aquí es dos
por cuatro lo voy a poner de este lado
el área sería dos centímetros por cuatro
centímetros cuatro centímetros y esto de
allí es ocho centímetros cuadrados pero
a la vez ocho es la cantidad de cubitos
que tenemos aquí porque aquí tenemos
nada más uno de profundidad vale bueno
esta idea nos puede ayudar a encontrar
el volumen del prisma porque ahora ya
sabemos que cada una de las rebanadas de
este estilo tienen ocho cubitos pero
tenemos tres de esas rebanadas porque la
profundidad es de 3 centímetros vale
entonces lo que tendríamos que hacer
para obtener el volumen o la cantidad de
cubitos que tenemos es ahora multiplicar
esto que nos quedó aquí abajo por tres
centímetros vale va otra vez la idea
tomamos esta rebanada de acá encontramos
el área de la superficie
área numéricamente es lo mismo que la
cantidad de cubitos en esa rebanada y
luego multiplicamos por la dimensión que
nos falta para obtener la cantidad de
rebanadas que tenemos y por lo tanto el
volumen vale bueno esta es la idea pero
vamos a ver cuánto nos quedan las
cuentas sería 2 por 4 es 8 8 por 13 24
entonces el volumen sería igual a 24 24
centímetros al cubo o bien 24
centímetros cúbicos vale bueno pero
bueno tú puedes decir hay otras formas
de tomar las superficies de tomar las
rebanadas a lo mejor yo no quiero cortar
por aquí sino quiero cortar digamos por
acá vale entonces ahora nos vamos a
tomar la rebanada como la de enfrente
entonces vamos a cortar por aquí y
queremos esta rebanada está bien la puse
aquí esa es otra forma de hacerlo y nos
debería dar lo mismo entonces vamos a
ver si sí vamos a hacer exactamente lo
que hicimos acá y vamos a ver que
obtenemos vale ahora que tenemos ahora
tenemos una rebanada tenemos esta
superficie y lo que yo digo es bueno
vamos a tomarnos la altura
nature es de 4 centímetros vamos a
tomarnos la profundidad la profundidad
es de 3 centímetros entonces ahora
tenemos que en esta en esta superficie
el área es de 3 centímetros
4 centímetros por y voy a tomar el color
azul por 4 centímetros y como el área es
de 3 x 4 o sea 12 centímetros cuadrados
entonces cada rebanada tiene 12 cubitos
unitarios y los podemos contar todavía 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 entonces todo
va muy bien ya tenemos la cantidad de
cubitos por rebanada de estas si
queremos obtener el volumen tendríamos
que multiplicar ahora por el largo vale
o sea lo que tendríamos que hacer es
ahora a copiarnos esta rebanada como
para acá como para acá vale y entonces
ahí tendríamos dos rebanadas cada una de
ellas con 12 cubitos con 12 cubitos
entonces teníamos que multiplicar esto
por 2 multiplicarlo por 2 y entonces nos
quedaría una vez más 24 centímetros
cúbicos vale bueno es exactamente lo
mismo que hicimos acá pero ahora con
otra rebanada y hay una tercera forma de
hacer las rebanadas que es cortar la
rebanada de hasta arriba o sea esta de
acá
esta de acá déjame hacerla con color
azul vale entonces sería esta de acá
arriba estamos considerando ahora esta
superficie mismísima idea ahora esta
superficie pues tiene déjame tomar el
color verde tiene tres centímetros de
profundidad tres centímetros tiene dos
centímetros de largo dos centímetros de
largo y por lo tanto ahora su área es
tres por dos sería tres centímetros tres
centímetros por dos centímetros dos
centímetros entonces su área de seis eso
nos dice que aquí tenemos seis cubitos
que claramente se pueden contar y si
ahora queremos determinar el volumen del
prisma tendríamos que multiplicar por
cuatro porque eso nos da la cantidad de
rebanadas que tenemos hacia abajo o sea
tendríamos aquí una rebanada más
hay una rebanada
de este lado tendríamos otra rebanada
algo así
vale este dibujo está quedando un
poquito feo pero no le hace y ahí
tendríamos la cuarta rebanada va
entonces tenemos que multiplicar esta
cantidad por cuatro centímetros cuatro
centímetros y por supuesto una vez más
nos queda 24 24 centímetros cúbicos vale
6 por 4 es 24 entonces no importa en qué
orden multiplicamos obtenemos 24
centímetros cúbicos vale o sea aquí
empezamos obteniendo esta área era 2 por
4 y luego multiplicamos por 3 y acá
empezábamos obteniendo el área de arriba
era 3 por 2 y luego multiplicamos por
cuatro pero por supuesto multiplicar en
distinto orden pues nos da el mismo
resultado y por lo tanto siempre tenemos
24 centímetros cúbicos de volumen vale
entonces aquí empezamos y bueno en esta
rebanada de acá empezamos con esta
superficie luego multiplicamos por la
profundidad luego esta superficie
multiplicamos por el largo y aquí esta
superficie y multiplicamos por el alto y
nos dio exactamente lo mismo vale
bueno entonces de esta forma si tenemos
un prisma rectangular cualquiera y
conocemos las dimensiones aquí son 2 3 y
entonces para encontrar el volumen basta
multiplicar 2 x 3 por 4 y eso justo nos
va a dar el volumen o bien la cantidad
de cubitos unitarios que caben en el
prisma vale entonces ya nada más pues
para terminar aquí nos quedaría dos
centímetros por tres centímetros tres
centímetros por cuatro centímetros basta
multiplicar cada una de las dimensiones
y aquí ya no hago la cuenta porque ya
vimos muchas veces que eso nos da 24
centímetros cúbicos